retired four-star general stanley
mcchrystal he has a new book risk a
user's guide and that's something the
general knows a lot about he had a long
military career including a commander of
u.s and international forces in
afghanistan from 2009 to 2010. for the
past 10 years he runs the mcchrystal
group a corporate consulting company
good morning stanley how are you doing
thanks for having me i appreciate it of
course now we'll get to your book in a
moment let's start with afghanistan
though top military officials they said
they recommended leaving a small force
in afghanistan which is a contradiction
to what president biden wanted to do
should they have done things differently
well it's tough decision you remember
the doha agreement negotiated by
president trump's administration said we
would pull every american soldier out so
president biden was left to the decision
either to abrogate that agreement or to
confirm it he actually delayed it but
then made the decision to go through
with the withdrawal i think the
assessment was the taliban who had held
off attacking americans during that
18-month period
wouldn't have
stopped doing that so it was a tough
call
had i made the decision or i had been
asked to recommend i probably would have
left
a residual american force but i was
emotionally wrapped up in the mission i
spent a long time there and i'm free to
admit i'm biased that's an important
acknowledgement an interesting one and
actually brings us to the book but i do
want one more question on afghanistan uh
keeping a force there the argument would
be that prevents al qaeda from making a
resurgence uh are you concerned or are
we capable of keeping al-qaeda out of
power or out of a a powerful situation
in the country without being there
it's difficult but the reality is global
terrorist groups like al qaeda or isis
can go a lot of places so afghanistan is
not unique in that standpoint they could
operate from pakistan or somewhere else
so i don't think it hugely increases the
threat to the united states homeland
my reason for leaving forces would be
partly that but the other reason is i
think we have a relationship with the
afghan people i think they had a chance
now they've struggled and they've made a
lot of mistakes but i actually think
that they have an opportunity to build a
nation and even going forward i don't
think that opportunity is dead so i'm
much more about the long-term strategic
partnership you know the area very well
general and as you watch this unfold did
you think that there was any way that it
could have gone
that it could have worked that the plan
could have worked the way it was
executed did you see that the withdrawal
yes well i think it certainly could have
it was a decision to try to get american
forces out with as little risk as
possible so to use speed the fact that
the defense forces of the afghan
military collapsed so quickly
it could have been predicted but it
wasn't a sure it might have happened it
didn't it was a
pretty effective information warfare
campaign that the taliban had been
mounting for a long time and so i don't
think it was shocking that that happened
but you know that's operations like that
are that way a certain amount of it's
fate and there's a lot of uh monday
morning uh quarterbacking a lot of what
we should have done we could have done
why didn't we do and i don't know if
that's necessarily fair well i think you
know you put people on the field
coaching the team are playing it feels
very different yeah and so i would say
you know
now it didn't go perfectly now in your
book you say one of the biggest changes
after 9 11 was how intelligence
community shares information
so does it surprise you how fast the
taliban took over
not really if you watched the trend of
history from about 2010 on the united
states was constantly signaling that we
were going to get out as soon as we
could
and then that sped up with the doha
agreement so the afghan people started
to calculate wow this is very dangerous
they lacked full
confidence in their own government for
some good reasons and so i think what
happened is a crisis of confidence just
came to a head
uh when we started the final pull-out
and so things collapsed pretty quickly i
love how you started your book you
started with you you may remember how it
started and you go into a scenario about
a chicago tourist returning from china
who's carrying this virus as it turns
out you were working on this book before
covet 19 this is not this was an
exercise that really didn't happen what
did you learn from this well you're
right we started i thought it was so
spot on stanley for something that
yeah that really came to be
we we started the book on risk and then
covet 19 started and it seemed to play
out what we were thinking which our
conclusion early on was the greatest
risk to us as us
and so we found out about covet 19 or
crimson contagion which was conducted in
2019 and it's a department of health and
human services exercise and it has a
scenario remarkably like what played out
in covet 19. and it told us that we were
not sufficiently prepared we were not
ready that's right and we weren't
coordinating well and then when covert
night team came even though we had the
lessons from just months before
we made every one of those mistakes
again i mean managing risk is arguably
the central challenge of life and the
central challenge for any country you
say we all have a risk immune system can
you define that and talk about the
factors exactly i would say first is we
have this fixation on external risks all
the things out there going to get us
right but when we look at when companies
fail for example it's almost always
internal problems
we have a human immune system every day
we are assaulted by what they predict is
ten thousand microorganisms any one of
which could make us sick or kill us and
yet we don't get up in the morning
worried about it because this miracle
system detects those threats assesses
them as dangerous or not
responds to them destroys the ones that
must and learns from it sort of the
principle of vaccination
only when our immune system is weakened
are we suddenly vulnerable to things
well we have risk immune systems in our
organizations and i would argue in our
wider society and when that risk immune
system is weakened or doesn't function
well suddenly things which really
shouldn't cause us huge problems covet
19 for example is not an amazingly 10
feet tall unbeatable virus right
we knew what to do about it we knew it
was coming and we got this miracle
vaccine at record speed and yet still
we struggle we struggle because our risk
immune system
is weakened yeah and that risk immune
system we
we define 10 factors
risk control factors communication
narrative diversity bias timing action
number of those and all of those operate
as a system and if we keep that healthy
and we can do that we have agency over
that
so risk is not always something terrible
to us it's also an opportunity to be
more resilient and it's about how we
handle it you say you chose a soldier's
life because you like taking risk what
does that say about you
well when i was young i looked at people
who were timid
and i decided i didn't want to be that
and so i wouldn't be timid i went into a
a line of business where i thought
i would be taught and forced to take on
risk and also to be honest you like the
idea of being viewed as someone who's a
risk taker be viewed as the bold of
course and it becomes self-reinforcing
it's a great book and apple application
that that we can use on many areas of
our life thank you so much general
stanley mcchrystal risk a user's guide
on sale right now very kind